Good morning, Hank! It's Monday!
Good Morning, Uncle Hank, It's Monday!
Yay, Henry!
Henry, show them the Puff.
Oooh, very puffy
So Hank, you'll never guess where I'm going this morning
Unless you guessed the dentist.
This seems like good weather for vlog driving
So Hank, the other day I saw this tweet
from Amanda Bynes.
Right Hank, so now that I'm home and my mouth hurts,
It belatedly occurs to me that among your abundant charms
is that you can probably name all six types of quarks,
but probably don't know who Amanda Bynes is.
Look Hank, he's already reading.
Reading pictures
Amanda Bynes is an American movie actress who I apparently follow on twitter.
Yes, I am ashamed.
So the other day Amanda Bynes tweets
"I hate it when people say I said things i didn't say! Stop putting words in my mouth!"
Then, less than 24 hours later, she tweets:
" 'Your imagination is your preview of life's coming attractions' - Albert Einstein"
And, Hank, in that tweet Amanda Bynes committed the
most common sin on the internet!
Confusing 'you're' and 'your?
No
Exposing yourself on chat roulette?
No! Misquoting Albert Einstein!
Much to my continuing annoyance,
the internet fails to appreciate the fact that
Albert Einstein was a physicist,
not a quotation-generation machine.
So, less than 24 hours after Amanda Bynes
complains that she's being misquoted all of the time,
she misquotes someone else.
People who make their lives public will be misquoted.
And if they don't like that,
they should make their lives private.
And that's reason 1 of 3 why
you won't see a ton of your nephew Henry in the forthcoming video blogs
I mean, it's not like you're gonna see none of him.
[baby noise]
But I want the choice of whether he has a private life to be his
Also, number 2. Hank, I don't know if this happened to you, but
when I was in high school, whenever I would take a girlfriend home to meet mom,
What am I saying,  "I don't know if this happened to you"? Of course it didn't happen.
You didn't have any girlfriends in high school.
The first thing mom did was pull out a photo album of baby pictures.
And she would bring the girl over and she would literally be like,
"Look at that little baby! Wasn't he cute?!
Look at his tiny little penis!
I'm telling you, when he came out of my body, I said, 'Are you sure that's a boy?'"
Meanwhile in the background, I'd be like, "Hi, uh, Mad-Eye Moody?
This is John Green. I'm gonna need a disillusionment charm ASAP."
Anachronism! -What?
Anachronism! There were no disillusionment charms when you were in high school!
Harry Potter hadn't been published!
You're an anachronism, version of me talking to me from a slightly different angle.
So, Hank, I don't want to tell embarassing stories of Henry
that instead of reaching an audience of one girlfriend,
reach an audience, of, you know, lots.
Right, so, but reason number 3:
Hank, you are a nerdfighter, and I am a nerdfighter,
and nerdfighters, you are nerdfighters.
But not everyone watching this video is a nerdfighter.
You know how I know, Hank? Because sometimes we get YouTube messages like this one
which I swear I am not making up.
I'm not gonna tell you his user name-I assume it's a him-
so that you don't spam him.
Hmmm "ok" isn't the first adjective that comes to mind.
Hank, the funniest thing about this message is not that it's sender
wants us to upload videos like hot kisses and other.
The funniest thing is that this user appears to be under the impression
that there are currently an inadequate number of videos on YouTube
featuring kisses and other.
And he thinks the only way to rectify this problem
is to reach out to the Vlogbrothers.
Hank, call me crazy, but I don't want that guy seeing too much of your nephew.
Hank, Henry is awesome. He loves his Aunt Katherine's quilt.
Thank you for the video you made.
Thank you to Maureen for being actual John Green so actually.
Nerdfighters, thanks for everything. We love you guys so much.
If you have any questions about the baby, I'll try to answer them in comments.
Hank, I'll see you on Wednesday.
Shhhhhhh
Henry is sleeping like a champion!